m
les
à
get up pour cette année 2010 est le
scarabée invite à se lever à se lever au
son de la musique afro-américaine dans
toute la ville pour tous les publics et
un concert pour débuter l'année
c'est un projet qui est né dans nos
têtes d'une envie de de partir de
changer un petit peu de la chanson
française
même si on aime beaucoup ça et de partir
un peu à la découverte d'un autre
continent
et puis c'est aussi un moyen d'aborder
plein d'autres questions puisque
l'histoire de cette musique elle est
vraiment lié à l'évolution de la société
américaine
à la question des droits civiques de
l'égalité des droits pour tous et ça
c'était vraiment un sujet qui nous
tenait à coeur
un voyage à travers le monde aussi avec
l'orchestré national de barbès le 25
février
le groupe franco algérien fêtera ses 20
ans ou encore une soirée pour la saint
patrick la fête irlandaise
c'est un des grands rendez vous de
l'année qui est très attendu par notre
public donc là le vendredi 17 mars on
aura un concert de musique celtique avec
le groupe les salles tic qui vont
visiter un peu tout le répertoire de les
causes du pays de galles à la bretagne
avec un show près l'arrivée
[Musique]
jusqu'à raz b mettra aussi à l'honneur
des artistes locaux
la saison reprend dès le 28 janvier